لذا فأنت تعمل مع الرئيس
ترامب وسانتا بشأن الموقف الإيراني السعودي
، هل تم تفويضك من قبله
للتوسط أو التسهيل عندما قال
الرئيس ترامب عندما كنت في نيويورك
أنه يجب عليك أن تحاول أن تكون
وسيطًا بين إيران و  لقد تحدثت مع الولايات
المتحدة إلى الرئيس روحاني
عندما كنت في إيران بشأن الولايات المتحدة
عرض وهذا وضع متطور ، لذا
دعنا نرى ما إذا كان سيصل إلى أي مكان ، يمكنك
أن تقول للرئيس روحاني
أنه قد تكون هناك بادرة حسن نية في
وقت ما قادمة إلى الولايات المتحدة
للمساعدة في تلك العلاقة الثنائية
ولكن الولايات المتحدة.  أكثر تعقيدًا بعض الشيء
، لذا لن أخوض في
الكثير من التفاصيل حول هذا الموضوع حتى يكون هناك
بعض الاستجابة من كلا الجانبين ، هل أنت
إيجابي
أعتقد ، لذلك أعتقد أن هناك إدراكًا
أعتقد أن الرئيس ترامب الذي تعرفه يقول
ما يريده الناس  يقول عنه
وينتقده ولكن على الأقل ما
يعجبني فيه أنه لا يؤمن
بالحروب